then this morning we see the financial man of vattenfall
is saying it in the newspaper
yes and nationalize the energy
that is not a solution
you know the vattenfall what last 2 years 800
million made a profit
that simply belongs to the Dutch taxpayer
that should be used
to lower that energy bill
Vattenfall
what now announced rates just to go again
Vattenfall a Swedish internship company
so a Dutch internship company
is a very crazy idea
but a sweat internship company in the Netherlands
fine and there this cabinet will immediately go billions
to transfer
part of which will disappear directly
in the Swedish treasury
is the minister
disagree that that is absurd for words
that the energy bill must be reduced
that we must also take back control
about a basic facility
as the energy